donc ça nous a donné envie de jouer un
petit jeu le juste laïque
[Applaudissements]
le jingle est arrivé que l'heure d'hiver
c'est juste prix mais mais mais pour des
laïcs voix et testez votre popularité
sur les réseaux sociaux
aof parce que vous en poster des photos
tous un à la une première regarder ce
beau bébé
on peut la voir enfin c'est pas une
photo volée c'est lui qui l'a postée
lui-même il est bon il sent bon le sable
chaud et sa photo cartonne sur instagram
mais il n'est pas le seul à exposer
c'est sûr plastique 1 vous avez la
concurrence regarder ses coûts c'est
grâce à leur petit jeu d'après vous qui
entre match et benjamin a eu le plus de
like m mathieu axial que mathieu il
allait retrouver sur ce plot de b&b le
gène de leurs moeurs international et là
on a un gros monsieur non on ne sait pas
faire
eh bien je vais vous dire la vérité
c'est mathieu mais ce qui est surprenant
1598 pour mathieu et 7421 il ya aussi un
bel éphèbe qui saisissent et jouant
comme ça aux petits délits au regard des
maximes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et lui ça donne quoi les nike alors il
ya d'autres cas de figure il y en a qui
sont prêts à tout pour récolter des like
it légèrement retouché les photos je ne
vise personne mais regarde les yeux
laser
ces retouches été bon la guyane reid
je veux montrer la vérité ça ces photos
retouchées line photos naturelles
maintenant regarder voilà
[Applaudissements]
bientôt coût des repas je vous remercie
parce que vous avez posté une photo de
nous deux et très franchement moi au
réveil je ressemble pas à ça et je
voudrais vous remercier
si on peut la voir non c'est pas c'est
pas du tout la photo que avec et je
pensais mais je crois qu'il avait un
copain chinois j'étais à l'école salut
mon ami mais j'adorais comme vous avez
été un petit peu après il fait croire sa
fille c'est une application qui paye
avec ses récits faire sa sélection mais
il s'agirait sa grinta des filtres alors
c'est la même chose ah oui pas tout mais
on est maquillée vous êtes maquiller il
y en a eu très long à chaque fois mais
ses équipiers habitudes du contenu dans
des émissions et badauds que de la
gueule et du contenant sait de quoi il
parle